don't worry our scientists aren't crazy
they're just trying to imitate German
singer annamaria Hefele oh she's singing
two tones at once how is she doing that
it's not quite as good as it yeah not
even close Helle but Anne has been
practicing singing two tones at once
called polyphonic overtone singing for
over a decade it's also a smash hit with
almost 8 million views online but what
exactly is this sirens song when someone
sings a note we actually are hearing a
whole bunch of different frequencies now
first of all there's the fundamental
tone and that's the lowest and the
loudest the one that we know we're
hearing but there's actually a lot of
overtones that are actually part of a
note as well and those aren't as obvious
to us and this is the key to what Anna
Maria is doing what Anna Maria can do is
filter out all the overtones except one
and amplify that one alongside the
fundamental frequency and that sounds to
us like two distinct notes so how is she
musically multitasking she's basically
putting the tongue up to the roof of her
mouth and curling it around a little bit
leaving a small space for air so it's
almost like creating a second mouth one
of the mouths is doing the fundamental
tone the other one is doing the overtone
what makes Anna Maria's so freaky is
that she can adjust independently the
tone of the fundamental tone and the
overtone she can move them up she can
move them down she can move them in the
same direction she can move them in
opposite directions
annamaria Hefele ah a woman with a voice
of two angels